what's popping suck heads it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
this is going to be a breakdown of Blade
2 the blade movie where both the hunter
vampires and the vampire Hunters become
the hunted like I am so excited to be
breaking down this beloved bloody sequel
so let's make like blade and just dive
into this thing shall we but of course
like always it would make me and Paul
extremely happy if you guys left a like
on this video and thought about
subscribing doing either one of those
two little things really help helps out
the channel but anyways Blade 2 here I
go Bladen again was written by David
goyer returning after writing blade 1
and he wrote it specifically with Geo
del Toro's wonderful directorial vision
in mind a director who does an
absolutely phenomenal job with this
movie goyer actually wanted GMO for
blade one as he was a massive fan of del
Toro's early filmography in particular
del Toro's 1993 directorial debut
vampire film Kronos as well as his 1997
film mimic Del Toro only agreed to do
Blade 2 Under the very specific
stipulation that he was allowed to make
the movie even scarier than the first as
making creepy ass movies was one of his
favorite things to do as you can
definitely see with the design of the
Reapers of this movie because God dang
are these things certified nightmare
fuel which is why GMO decided to open
the movie with a scene showing just how
disturbing his new creation was with the
opening shot establishing the film's
primary shooting location of Prague in
the Czech Republic most of the filming
for the movie was actually done in
Prague which worked out super well for
the production as they were able to take
advantage of the Region's incredible
Gothic architecture while also being
able to purchase a couple of abandoned
factories for a pretty damn good price
and when the movie first opens with
Jared nomac attacking one of the vampire
nation's blood banks guo made sure to
gross out as many people as possible by
having nomac open his head like a God
dang hot dog so so that noac could snack
on some smug suck heads trying to take
advantage of the homeless like I truly
love this opening because you can
immediately see that the blade Universe
has just introduced a new kind of super
intense vampire one that Gear mod Del
Toro says he purposely modeled after
leeches mainly because leeches are all
about one specific thing finding a blood
source to feed because in G mod del
Toro's opinion at that point in popular
media vampires became too much like
humans as a lot of vampires and fiction
were infused with a lot of elements like
romance and human emotion rather than
being depicted as bloodthirsty humanoid
monsters with an animalistic drive to
hunt and consume and Del Toro really
liked how real life leeches did not
evolve to become these super attractive
beings that were obsessed with finding a
mate and how they were one trck minded
beings mainly focused on looking for the
nearest warm-blooded body to feed so
deloro made sure to make the rapers as
disgusting as he possibly could on the
outside as well as with their biology on
the inside as we see later during the
reaper autopsy scene and like I alluded
to in my breakdown of the first blade
movie morbius was actually the character
that the writers of Blade 1 wanted to
bring in as the main antagonist for the
sequel but unfortunately the rights to
morbius were of course sitting on Sony's
lap and thus could not be used by new
line Cinema so they opted for Jared
nomac instead after this scene we get
the intro credits which include a
flashback to blad's birth scene that we
saw at the start of Blade 1 with Blade's
mother Vanessa Brooks making a very
brief appearance then right after this
when blade is introducing Whistler we
get a quick flash of what looks like a
police report concerning an event that
took place at 7:00 at a family residence
in Washington DC with the names Whistler
comma Susanna comma Sarah comma Becky at
the top of the page those names are very
likely whistler's dead wife and two
daughters Susanna Whistler Sarah
Whistler and Becky Whistler in the first
movie we learned that all three of them
died died in a vampire attack which is
what prompted Whistler to start his life
of vampire hunting in their name then
the movie starts with blade chasing down
some vampires who try to hop on their
red and black motorcycles to escape with
red and black of course being the
favorite colors of vampires due to their
associations with blood and the Darkness
of night then we get a badass display of
the day Walker Superior half vampire
genome when we see him jump from the
very top of this building in order to
keep those vampires from escaping with
blade of course being completely
computer generated for this jump after
this we see blade using his black and
red jacket to taunt and Dodge his as
salant like Spanish matadors use red
capes to taunt and Dodge Bulls I
particularly love how when blade causes
this red motorcycle to wreck we can see
a cow winking on the wall in the
background to accentuate this matador
bull them this wall is an advertisement
for a brand of milk seemingly called
tasty mow produced in the tasty mow crey
that's served as a front for the
vampires that were keeping and torturing
Whistler we can see boxes of the milk
that that crey distributes next to the
vampire goons doing drugs in the
following scene right before blade
murders them all to rescue his old white
dad then when blade and Whistler return
to their hide out scud references Frank
Miller's 1986 Batman comic The Dark
Knight Returns while listening to
gorillas on My Mind by the gorillas and
red man like scud is definitely a big
fan of comic books and the superhero
genre in general and as he can be seen
wearing a Hellboy T-shirt with the bprd
logo on it later on in the film with
bprd of course standing for the Bureau
of paranormal research and defense from
the Hellboy Comics director gaml Delo
was of course a big fan of the Hellboy
franchise and he would prove it later on
by having his very next movie after
Blade 2 B Hellboy 2004 also starring Ron
Perman and he would of course also go on
to direct 2008's Hellboy 2 after making
Pan's Labyrinth scuds name is also a
possible reference to the comic book
series scud the Disposable assassin
which is about a society in the far
future that allows anyone to buy a robot
Assassin from a vending machine
disposable robot assassins that
self-destruct after their target has
been eliminated scud is the name of one
of these robot assassins who becomes a
Merc For Hire after getting their own
autonomy by keeping the human target
they were supposed to assassinate alive
in the hospital therefore keeping his
self-destruct programming at Bay if this
is the case then I think that scud being
named after scud the Disposable assassin
is very fitting considering that all the
vampires view the familiars as
disposable humans and although scud
would end up being scum he is a scummy
scud with good taste as scud can be seen
watching The Powerpuff Girls multiple
times throughout this movie like when he
first meets Whistler while he's chilling
in the garage and even while he was
running van surveillance while the rest
of his friends went partying in Satan's
nightclub we can also see some Powerpuff
Girls footage playing while scud and
Whistler are building their light bomb
together the Powerpuff Girl episodes
used in this movie were season 2 episode
8's down and dirty season 1 episode 18's
bubble vicious and season 3 episode 2's
the main event the down and dirty
Powerpuff Girls episode that scud
watches when he first meets Whistler is
an episode where Buttercup stanks up all
of Townsville with her nasty superhuman
body odor when she refuses to take a
bath with her sisters because baths are
for sissies Buttercup is usually the
character on the screen when we see scud
watching The Powerpuff Girls show which
makes sense if you consider that later
on in the movie Blade would go on to
call scud a [__] for not wanting to
help during the autopsy possibly
implying and foreshadowing that blade
himself could smell scuds own stench
from a mile away I love how Whistler
even calls him skid when he first talks
to him further foreshadowing his shitty
nature as a vampire familiar and fun
fact about blad's headquarters in this
movie it actually used to be a factory
that made missiles for the Soviets in
the past so the film crew figured why
not convert this old weapons facility
for missiles into a vampire weapons
facility for blade which was a dope
choice in my opinion but that facility
would soon of course be infiltrated by
both Assad and Nissa dressed in their
cool vampire ninja outfits that guo Del
Toro designed himself after being
heavily inspired by the anime genre Del
Toro has always been a massive fan of
Japanese anime and has gone on record to
say that the dope ass action found in
anime is what very much inspired the
action sequences of Blade 2 and we
actually get slight hints towards Scot's
allegiance to the vampires during this
ninja infiltration scene the first time
is when scud licks the blood off of his
finger after Whistler busts his face
with a gun and the second time is when
scud compliments Nissa and Assad suits
in a Please Don't Shoot Me we're on the
same side kind of way I mean hell Scott
probably even designed those suits for
them but anyways after this Nissa and
Assad bring blade to damaso's
headquarters at calaban Industries with
calaban of course being a reference to
the half human half monster hybrid
character calaban from William
Shakespeare's play The Tempest this
makes sense as calaban Industries was
secretly making half vampire half
monster hybrids with damaso's attempts
to perfect the vampire genome the symbol
on the helicopter landing pad even
appears to be a double helix to
foreshadow damaso's mad science
experiments then a little later after
this Assad introduces blade to his new
team of elite vampire Warriors the blood
pack which is of course a clever play on
the medical blood packs used to store
extracted blood after Assad introduces
Daz Crawford's lighthammer he quickly
introduces ligh Hammer's girlfriend
verain a character that was originally
supposed to be played by actress Tracy
Lords as verain was first imagined to be
the twin sister of Raquel the female
vampire from the very beginning of the
first blade film but the character was
then retooled to be played by marit Vel
keil and following Tony Curran's priest
we are introduced to snowman as played
by martial arts movie Legend Donnie Yen
who also served as this movies fight
choreographer because you know gal Del
Toro isn't a freaking idiot and knows a
goddamn baller when he sees one then
after this we meet Chupa as played by
actor Matthew schules and fun fact about
Chupa dude's name literally means to
suck in Spanish as it is based on the
Spanish word chupar and it's a damn good
thing that Chupa is a vampire because if
my name was suck and I wasn't a vampire
people would probably assume that I was
some Notorious freak drinking ski on the
streets to make ANS meat and finally we
meet Reinhardt played by actor Ron
Pearlman an actor who has done a number
of projects with guod Del Toro these two
are two P's in a pod man with the most
notable amongst those projects being of
course as Hellboy in the first two
Hellboy movies and let me tell you man
your boy Reinhardt is so damn cool so
cool in fact that he is the only
character who never takes off his
sunglasses throughout the entire course
of the film which is kind of nuts when
blade and Reinhardt have their first
face off upon meeting Reinhard asks
blade if he can blush which is actually
a racist comment that someone in real
life said to Wesley Snipes in the past
Snipes insisted that this line be
included as part of reinhardt's dialogue
in order to help blade truly despise
that character and then later on while
the blood pack is doing their cool
badass slow motion walk to the club
behind them you can see a giant Neon
sign with the word Radu on it Radu was
actually the name of real life Prince of
wakia Radu the handsome the brother of
the ruler of wakia Vlad the Impaler
originally born as Vlad Dracula Vlad the
Impaler has been said to have inspired
the creation of braah Stoker's character
Count Dracula having the name of vlad's
brother in the background behind Nissa
and this vampire team could have been
this film's way of teasing the coming
revelation of nissa's own brother being
the main threat of the film that neon
sign flickering red and blue is very
likely symbolic of this team up of the
warm-blooded day Walker with this cold
blooded blood pack as Whistler is
staring at the group through his thermal
scope a few moments later you can see
that Blade's body is the only body
glowing red as he is the only
warm-blooded vampire among them with the
rest of the blood pack showing up as a
cool blue but anyways the House of Pain
nightclub scene that follows was
actually filled with around 400 extras
in this singular room and while Gamal
Del Toro was a little nervous about
managing all of those people he actually
ended up truly loving the experience as
all 400 of them were incredibly fun and
hardworking people however because they
were all dancing for so long the room
quickly started to smell like crazy boo
which made the director wish the
production added 400 deodorant sticks to
the budget but anyways as the blood pack
walked through the house of pain blade
is disgusted at all the freaky [__] that
all of these vampire youths are up to
like French kissing with razor blades in
their mouths and mutilating their own
backs for fun but I guess that's sort of
the point of a club called the house of
pain and to underscore this pain theme
the backdrop of the stage is a giant red
Sun the number one celestial object of
pain for all dark Denison of the Vampire
Nation but actually fun fact about red
suns in Marvel Comics they're actually
one of blad's main weaknesses much like
they are for Superman in DC Comics
recently in 2019s Avengers number 27 we
can see blade getting the energy drained
out of him as the Avengers fly near a
series of red suns in outer space but
anyways as priest walks through the
crowd he's disgusted because a lot of
the clubbing vampires aren't
pure-blooded vampires like him and his
team clearly showing how racist
damaskino Squad of vampires have been
brought up to be which makes sense
considering that guo Del Toro
deliberately made damaskinos himself to
be a super racist fascist of a vampire
that valued only the genetically pure of
his race which is why damaskinos cast
his own son out as soon as his
experimentations poisoned nomax DNA
anyways a little later Nissa heads
upstairs to look around for Reapers but
what she doesn't find is Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson was originally supposed
to make a quick Cameo as a vampire
handling a bunch of human remains but
for reasons unknown Michael Jackson
could not make it for this scene they
did end up filming that moment with
another actor but ended up scrapping
that moment entirely as a deleted scene
and then after the Reapers start
attacking the club we get this moment of
Li Hammer trying to get a resurrected
Reaper off of him this particular Reaper
was a combination of practical and
computer generated effects as some of
these shots of that Reaper attack were
of a completely robotic Reaper G mod
Delo did not like the idea of over
relying on CGI to craft his cinematic
Illusions so he had the Blade 2 design
team craft the upper torso of a Reaper
in a moving robot with realistic skin so
that audiences wouldn't have to deal
with that uncanny valley feeling that
came with a lot of CG from that era and
later a little fun Doctor Strange Easter
egg can be seen when blade and nomac
fight in the church behind nomac you can
see what appears to be the closed Golden
Eye of Doctor Strange's eye of agamotto
designed the way it used to be in the
Marvel Comics before the mcu's influence
then after this church scene we very
ironically have to watch a priest die as
priest begs for Chupa to kill him in
order to prevent becoming a Reaper
chuper mutters the words a Man Without
Fear for shooting his comrade which
definitely feels like a reference to
Marvel's Main Man Without Fear Daredevil
then after Whistler finds a dying Reaper
the blood pack take that Reaper to be
cut open and examined but you know not
so fun fact about this scene apparently
around 30 members of the film crew got
temporarily blinded from all the UV
lights that they used in this scene
which is kind of nuts while the gang
gets ready for their underground assault
blade quotes the Chinese philosopher
General sunu when he tells Whistler that
he intends to to keep his friends close
and his enemies closer but when he does
gaml deloro makes sure to symbolically
Place scud right behind blade in the
frame as scud would prove to be Blade's
enemy in Disguise the whole time by the
end of the film then the blood pack head
to the sewers of prag in order to
attract and Destroy some Reapers but do
you know what's even crazier than using
a Reaper's nut juice to hunt Reapers
down nothing because you know that's
pretty freaking crazy but did you know
that all of these tunnels were actually
built By Hand by the set designers in
Prague and all the tunnels they built
were as long as a freaking football
field like that absolutely blows my mind
because I would not have been able to
guess that at all like this feels like a
real location that I could go to if I
chose to live my life as a ninja turtle
in Prague but what I could guess was
that these vampires were definitely
going to betray Blade the first chance
that they got which is a prediction that
blade makes earlier in the film that
comes true when Reinhardt and Demo's
vampire goons knock blade out and take
him back to damaso's layer at calaban
Industries the interior of damaso's
layer was actually designed by Hellboy
Creator and comic book artist Mike mola
in case you know you didn't already know
that Del Toro was all about that Hellboy
Life comic book artist Tim Brad street
was also heavily involved with making
concept art as well the massive clock in
damaso's layer that can be seen when
blade first arrives at calaban
Industries is actually based on the
famous astronomical clock in Prague that
has been around since 1410 so I have a
strong feeling that damaskinos himself
is probably at least as old as that
clock and not only does this clock track
the time but it also tracks the position
of the sun and the moon which are things
that a vampire very much needs to know
at all times the character of deminos
himself especially his pale skin and
bald head were heavily based on the
famous vampire NOS feratu from the
well-known 1922 German adaptation of the
Dracula Tail as damaso's human familiar
Conan puts blade on a slab so that the
vampires can d drain him of his blood
much like what happened in the first
blade film we can notice that blade in
this movie has a number of new tattoos
than he had in the last with Wesley
Snipes revealing that blade gets a new
tattoo after he has a particularly
memorable vampire hunting Adventure as
each tattoo tells a story weird fact
about coonan though Carl Rhoden the
actor who played the character actually
had all of his lines dubbed over by a
British actor in post because apparently
he was using a super thick Czech accent
that audiences found a little bit too
much for the movie and finally at the
very end of the film blade of course
ties up some Loose Ends by killing Rush
The Vampire at the very start of the
film specifically in London inside of an
adult parody of Buckingham Palace called
Effingham Palace I can't say the f word
here because YouTube doesn't like it
with Rush being played by actor Santiago
sagur who has worked with gal deloro on
a number of films after this including
both Hellboy movies as well as the first
Pacific Rim film but anyways that is it
for this breakdown of Blade 2 thank you
guys so much for joining me and just
listening to me talk about random blade
facts you guys are amazing you can
follow me at mastertainment on Twitter
or YouTube or Instagram or wherever I am
on the internet but most importantly do
not forget to follow Paul and me here on
heavy spoilers because this is where
it's at we always got some great stuff
for you guys and you don't want to miss
it but yes thanks again for watching
this Marvel breakdown I cannot wait to
do the next one and I'll see you guys
next time bye